I heard a very beautiful story about you
well that you're a giving guy in the
sense that Michael che who is now
successful on Saturday Night Live I
heard and tell me if it's true and I
love this if it is that when he was
doing stand-up you pulled him aside and
you were already you know famous
obviously and you ever accomplished and
you say he's a very smart I love her
funny smart funny guy but you pulled him
aside in a club and you said look I hope
you don't mind but I'm gonna give you
some advice here you need to get away
from the mic stand
yeah what does that mean get away from
why did you tell him I got the mic stand
and moving it to the side cuz you got an
environment there use your whole
environment you got to walk the stage I
don't give a [ __ ] how big it is
you got pockets in love over here and
audience pakal's never neglect no part
of your audience in the back you got a
project so your voice is heard in the
back why do I want to do it you stand up
cuz you cuz if you want you wanna do you
want them to see you you want to like
that leaning on the mic stand that's
that's a bad habit you pick up in the
club know you ain't never see Eddie
Eddie Murphy use the whole stage right
what your prize those days I use the
whole stage
all right environment are you standing
there telling jokes nah I don't tell
jokes man it's just like always
I tell the truth on stage that's why
everybody laugh cuz you can identify and
relate with it no matter who you are
were you from the truth is the truth I
would give a [ __ ] of you live in
Bangladesh the truth is the truth is
comedy like music in the sense that
remember like a film yes remember Oasis
they would just stand there and play and
it there was not a lot of stage presence
but when you see Mick Jagger running
around and you see him on come on that's
a show that's a show so Michael che was
standing there I just or move around
more well you must have seen something
we've sometimes we get stuck in a box
did he take again edition didn't know he
loved me I love che right we get we get
because I started off that way and then
I had someone like Jimmy Mack give me
advice right so I just passed it on
that's knowledge knowledge is like love
you can't do nothing with it but passing
on so I just passing on some is dope was
worthy and he worthy